oh
i don't know
gq i'm buying both i don't care i don't
care about your rules
hey i'm issa rae and i'm about to go on
a gq shopping spree
with their credit card
[Music]
music
let's take a look at some music
city girls
period what is this the vinyl
i love to see girls i'm co-producing a
show with them called ravish in miami
coming out next year
obviously i already have this album but
i'd love to own it in the flesh
oh blood orange you're not gonna make me
buy one album and one of them is already
like a business partner so i'm biased
but blood orange is actually also
doing the music for rap [ __ ] so he's
also
collaborating love him his music is from
the future but it's also retro used his
music on insecure a lot
huge fan
y'all put some drake on here y'all know
how i feel about drake certified lover
boy
yeah okay 11.99 um
kanye west donda no thanks all right
music summary i'm definitely i'm gonna
go with see girls oh
i don't know
gq i'm buying both i don't care i don't
care about your rules i'm buying both
i'm buying city girls and blood orange
sorry
thank you so much
okay cars listen i'm terrible with cars
but i like electric cars a lot let's see
what
we have going on here
oh it's like you knew
2022 tesla model x 113
940.
listen it's a tesla i have one i love
them my tesla used to be blue so i
called it blueberry blueberry boot but
then
you know i started getting recognized
and my windows aren't tinted it's very
you know noticeable and i just recently
got a wrap during the pandemic intensive
windows and you could swear i'm bad
[ __ ] in this so
i'm a little fly
what the [ __ ] is a rivion what is a jeep
is this electric
what okay i'm easily swayed because this
[ __ ] is fire seventy thousand dollars
wait it must go like five miles
without being plugged in it can drive
through three feet of water i need that
we're in a drought but you never know
it goes 340 euros and it's only 70 000
is this [ __ ] out
is this car out how come nobody's put me
on to this yeah i want an electric suv
and this is
fire
okay
1976 cadillac
castillon is that you say it fleetwood
estate wagon 33 000 absolutely not this
is a hearse like you can hide bodies in
here i guess if i were to take a second
career as a murderer i might consider
this but you know everybody will find me
but this is not really my steez
2022 mclaren spider oh
i'm a big spider man fans anything
spider centered
319 thousand 000 just kidding um this is
not that fly
turbocharger takes it from a standing
start to 60 miles per hour in just 2.8
seconds
wow
that's a sports car right like
this would be sexy but it's not for me
and it's not electric then no why am i
going backwards you know what i'm saying
like i'm in the future all right the car
summary as much as i love the tesla this
r1s
is fire and i want to try that out for
70 000
i'm going with it
you'll see me rolling
so i've been meaning to go on a weekend
getaway
let's
see what they're talking about
invisible house in joshua tree joshua
tree i think about like drugs and
shrooms as a private pool pool view and
a patio damn this is nice as [ __ ] this
mirrored 22 story horizontal skyscraper
virtually disappears into the
surrounding desert landscape god dang
look at it at night it's like it's on
mars or some [ __ ] the sky doesn't even
look like our sky this is a rich sky
okay
tree house point six hundred dollars a
night it's the trillium it roosts
16 feet high and a tremendous cedar tree
the soaring walls of windows with a
total of 80 pains am i
seven like what do i need a tree house
for
okay i get it you know what when i was
little i
desperately wanted a tree house up until
i was 12 and then when my mom found a
house to rent and it had a tree house
and i was ecstatic i would dream about
that tree house every single night i was
like oh we finally got one
and then when we moved in
it had hella bugs in it i forgot that
it's a tree house you know it's in a
tree bugs live in a tree
spiders live in a tree they lay spider
eggs to be in the corners of the tree
house like why would i want to be in
there how am i supposed to solve
mysteries and inspires you know in the
tree house
never got in it um no thanks
sonoma california wine country fifteen
thousand dollars a night
fifteen thousand dollars like are they
giving you
unlimited bottles of wine every night
like what comes with that price views of
alexander valley and mount saint helena
if i knew what those places were i'd
probably be impressed
okay
it's got a nature feel i have so much
respect for nature but i don't
want to be in it you know i do love
vineyards but i like
the vines to be squeezed into a drink
already like i don't need to like be
amongst them you know
coconuts palace roman tower sweets 447
a night what is this big ass champagne
okay a seven foot champagne glass
whirlpool overlooking the living room
it's a little too pink for me and
burgundy and the champagne glass looks
dirty
i'm like how do you climb to get into
that glass like i would feel stupid
climbing in there like i would feel
immediately unsexy like that i had to do
that
rose petals on the bed i don't need all
that the heart-shaped jacuzzi okay it's
it's kind of fly it's still too much
burgundy are they cleaning the jacuzzi
like couples are clearly [ __ ] in here
and so there's like
a lot of other juices that i don't want
i would honestly have to bring some
lifestyle wipes if i stay here because
all right
you know what i'm definitely without a
doubt going for this invisible house in
joshua tree i'm booking it
[Music]
ooh jewelry
so i actually
just recently bought my most expensive
piece of jewelry like ever in life a
couple months ago there were some
diamonds tiffany earrings that i bought
for a special occasion i felt like a
boss like i felt i felt rich but i don't
know if i'd do that again but with gq's
money
let's do it
this is an mm6 meso margella green flock
diamond ring
is it actually diamond 275
band ring and green flux 100
no i don't want my [ __ ] to look like
artificial grass i appreciate it but
it's like this is like teletubby jewelry
i don't want to look moldy
i would respect this on someone else i
wouldn't personally rock it matteo 14
karat gold malachite and diamond
earrings 3 000
i like to wear the same pieces for the
most part
daily you know i'll switch it up for
special occasions but i like statement
pieces that are my pieces
this is really gorgeous but you know i'm
not in love with it green isn't my color
so custom gold grills
tri-color diamond cut with diamond dust
iced fangs this is fire 4 400. you can
get yours done in 10k 14k or 18k gold
the fangs takes ic to a whole new level
giving you all three colors of gold in
one grill i will rock
the [ __ ] out of this i would buy this in
a heartbeat i have a couple of girls i
feel like i i dabbled the first pairs
that i got were like fangs i just wanted
you know diamond and crusty thing to
match my tiffany diamonds earrings
i got a bar and i rocked that to the
emmys and it was like a
diamond-encrusted bar with fangs and
then i got a gold bar with frames but
i've yet to get
like
all this
laced up you know
okay so this is
the midas touch finger caps oh this is
cute
like i would rock this right now and
it's 220 is it for the whole set or is
it like per
her finger like my ring is loose right
now i don't know what it is about my
fingers but they gain and lose weight so
quickly it's crazy i would have to get
them custom fitted you know
obviously all right so
i'm definitely gonna get the most
expensive thing forty four hundred
dollar girls that's what i'm getting
because these are gorgeous i'm gonna add
this to the car
thank you
[Music]
close let me tell you i have no patience
when it comes to shopping for clothes i
need to know what i want
get in there and get out
but gq is hooking me up so let's see
what y'all have to offer in the clothes
department oh
this model doesn't even look happy to be
wearing this dress but i feel like i
could rock the [ __ ] out of it it is an
aviative
multi-color cutout dress 430 dollars
you know i feel like it's giving me a
little 70s vibe the mold ring would set
this dress off
i think that that's an aesthetic each
piece is constructed using the highest
quality of fabrics prove it this looks
like lycra or spandex
95 polyester
you just said the highest quality of
fabrics yeah i'm going to pass
okay rick owens black net tank dress
1325
this is kind of fire i'll have to be
like
you know securing my [ __ ] i don't have
to be working out
to rock this but i will rock this
without a doubt it's a little
cover-up situation it makes me feel
naughty dominatrixy i'll probably wear
this to the club i'll wear this to the
beach i could wear anywhere i could wear
this to a house party like this feels
versatile but i could i would only wear
it once
it makes an impression
and i don't want people to be like girl
why are you wearing them fishnets on
your body again like chill
so special occasions
i'm on claire pierre what the oh
pharrell i remember seeing this this
cover was fire
let me tell you something about pharrell
he could rock anything
this is 23 000
pharrell isn't trying to settle he can
make anything work anything looks good
on him does it look good on me no i
could not pull this off i would look
like a mountain i would look like a
volcano in this
this suit alexander mcqueen first of all
their suits are amazing i got to wear a
couple of them for insecure this season
custom made and i wanted to take them
home and red is one of my favorite
colors
silk satin straight leg pantsuit 4 700
sold it's inspired by the flag and
national costume of whales well i don't
need to know that but
um
i'm sold i'm definitely without a doubt
buying this fancy there's some ball [ __ ]
some fly [ __ ]
education oh education i love that wrote
out in school of design sculpture degree
four years
77
280. i
think design is amazing but sculpting
am i gonna go to school for four years
for that [ __ ]
no
but let's see what else you have
harvard divinity school master of
divinity the study of religion i can do
that on my own for 35 824 dollars i
don't want to be
in this kind of company it doesn't sound
like fun
to me you know
penn state
astrobiology dual title program that's
kind of fly 39 248 dollars astrobiology
is a field devoted to the exploration of
life outside of earth
and to the investigation of the origin
and early evolution of life on earth
honestly this would influence my writing
taking a course like this i want to
expand into different genres so this
might be a yes
mit joint program oceanography applied
ocean science and engineering five years
133
625 dollars
i like this because it's also
sustainability focus it cares about the
environment which i do too and the ocean
is such a big mystery
i just don't have time to figure it out
it's not gonna be on me if it's up to me
in five years the earth is done it's
toast
i'm gonna go with
penn state astrobiology and i get to
have a phd you have to call me dr ray
what sounds like a villain
[Music]
thank you guys so much for shopping with
me i expect all these gifts and all
these programs as soon as i walk out i
added it to the cart so thank y'all so
much
for helping me shop